so this talk addresses basically this
version perfect introduction thank you
because it addresses I always think if I
talk about technical stuff I try to say
hey me and my team how what did we
encounter in the first place because we
all start with things oh that's really
simple there's a nice tutorial let's get
this started and we have like uh
um a hello world or something working
like five minutes and all the rest that
comes afterwards so this talk is based
on use cases so use cases around data
hubs around data services around
building domain-driven data service
clients around it on premise for the
cloud mixed and of course a lot of
migration as probably some of you will
already have guests already
um we also cover like inclusive access
so business there's also like these
business users with Excel that should be
covered as well and microservices and of
course fast API is a very uh popular
choice nowadays and many people follow
just like why choose fast API and I'm
lazy so this is what GPT told me and I
know chat GTP and I I now double check
facts and then double check the facts
and it was accurate so
um it's fast it's the first it's the
first web framework I think also part of
the success of fast API is it's very
similar to the design of flask which was
also very popular in the python
Community already and fast API just took
it things to another level
um so it it was a really fast growing
project as well it gives us a very
scalable flexible architecture for
building things but
as Max said in the introduction you
start with it you think it's easy and I
would like to introduce you to some use
cases Solutions and things you probably
don't need to stumble across as we did
I'm Alexander I'm part managing partner
at koenigs week we have a booth outside
come by with PlayStation to win
um oh now now now I've got you I'm also
part of multiple
python ecosystem zero python this
conference for me community and
knowledge exchange is very very
important and if you want to discuss
things with me come talk to me
I also have to do a disclaimer because
some parts might be a bit opinionated or
exaggerated I want to have a full
disclaimer
um I still love fast API so it's not
like a talk why not to use API just like
to how can we make use of API fast API
better and also it's a very active
community and I especially also want to
thank everybody who contributed code
tutorials whatever in the ecosystem and
I think Sebastian is doing an amazing
job as organizing and enabling this
community
let me introduce you to a prototypical
fast API Journey there's a requirement
fast API utilizes the open API standard
which has been established for many
years so if you don't have haven't heard
about it just like a quick preview this
is like these nice Pages where people
have documentation generated from code
on web pages so you can interact and
understand the API way easier
um this is also I would say an industry
standard nowadays and of course you look
for framework very likely you sample of
course fast Aid and nowadays there used
to be others like I also like connection
but unfortunately that was neglected for
some time and fast API just is now a bit
better
um
you can do like a hello world in five
minutes and it gets you going really
fast and of course of soon you say okay
I only need to know fast API because
this solves all my problems this is like
a typical mistake humans engineers
I do oh that sounds really great I've
never tried it it's must be just so good
and perfect and it promises everything
and you can build stuff on tutorial at a
time and this is how many people start
to use fast API
and some next steps on that journey of
course you want to add more endpoints
you want to add more request models your
desk response models you want
to have contracts you want to make sure
everybody talks to your API and
standardized well-readable easy to
understand fashion and of course you
also want to you
say okay this is the feedback you're
going to get and here's the
documentation for it and of course once
you get started you have more complex
models you want to validate data you
want to be consistent and consistent in
naming and of course
of course operation stuff like
middleware for logging or contacts like
correlation IDs and on and on and some
challenges I found
on on that Journey was when we were
working on it you just don't basically
need to know fast API fast API is
more than just fast API pedantic is a
very big part of fast API under the hood
Starlet is a really good big part under
the hood UV cone for running the servers
um so
you have to be aware that one challenge
is everything is solved by just like
another layer of obstruction so it's
basically like like an onion which is
deeper and deeper and deeper and it's
all really well implemented it all works
really well together but it's not it's
usually like you really have to you're
not really sure which which framework is
responsible now for this and that
um it's very packed
um and of course you need to think about
designing sustainable endpoints that are
understandable you want to think about
your modeling also like how can you
enable your organization by these models
because building one service for small
team is easy but once you have
a definition dumb you want others in
other departments also to use it and not
to have them reinvent other
models and this actually also already
starts with hey is that ID is that asset
ID and all these tiny questions that
need to be answered
um and so the summary is not a summary
of the talks or summaries so what I want
to talk about today is
fast API is built this is built on the
shoulders of giants in two or two to two
par top two feel about it and create
tutorials but is this documentation from
a middleware use case and also how not
to repeat yourself with pedantic and I
really want to start with pedantic
because I think pedantic who knows
pedantic
well almost everyone yeah like working
hard so let me introduce everyone who
isn't familiar with pedantic yet
pedantic you can build models you can
Define models with pedantic so it's very
similar to data classes
um it's which is basically up it's so
it's it's you can also like as metal
models say this is like an improved data
class so bad data classes with extras or
benefits it's really easy to Define an
endpoint as we see above here like have
a response model asset and asset is just
defined as a class that has an asset ID
a name and a currency code and this is
just like being used by pedantic already
to generate so for example the
documentation which we already saw in
the open API standard so actually
pedantic does a lot of the heavy lifting
it's
it's uh it parses the input data and
and I think there's also like a often
very understood if I don't think is
understood here with because it parses
the data so still if you give a list of
integers of strings there which can be
passed to an integer you pedantic will
make a list of integers there so it's
not validating no sorry please I'm
expecting a list of integers
just from scratch
um because it's still built to work in
rest
slash web applications and of course if
you send something to a server as a Json
or via URL or query parameters of course
a query parameter is always text so and
of course pedantic takes the text and
parses it and said okay yeah that's the
list my composite it and enter just all
good but it will not complain if you
send something which is uh yeah it will
not complain if you always send
something that can be parsed in an
integer just like it's a very simple and
basic example so it does not validate
aggressively it seems okay it looks good
and I can I can basically transform it
into the
target format
and
there's many misunderstandings with
pedantic for example so it's really easy
to
build a model to add documentation I
kept it short so it fits on the slides
of course you can do way better and
descriptions what what is inside give
example data which are again in
displayed in the open API standard so
it's very good to make people understand
what what which data models do we expect
Which models do you return what
structures do you return and respect and
for example like the validator validator
costs I think a few hours of Lifetime
with many developers because I think
validators are not the optimal name for
that because the validator is you can
add a validator to validate asset ID
here and we just want to validate is it
is it an integer
um between 0 and
999 and my expectation was hey it's a
validator and if the assert doesn't
raise all good it's a validator right
so because I've also worked with other
validator Frameworks as
um severals before and actually if
servers said no it's not an integer it
raises but here actually we get a none
returned so for the validator you always
have to you can do land many checks you
can use it for data mangling or
cleansing which is really handy as well
um so what you really need to know okay
if you want not something like none back
or not not Mac you have to return the
original value if it passes all tests
and um yeah so it's a great feature once
you understand it and we will hear a bit
more about it later
another good thing is to know pedantic
defaults
um pedantic comes with from well chosen
built in defaults but you should not
just you should be aware of them
um I just give you a very simple use
case
imagine we have our rest API defined
with response and request models so we
basically know which data or how the
state the Json in this case has to be
structured when we send it off to the
back end and of course we have a return
here so what happens there was a
front-end developer and said oh I have
this new feature requests and I just add
something extra to the Json and
everybody said hey cool we have models
we are basically safe because like if
something does not really fit to the
back end the back end will raise a
validation error
but in this case it didn't has anybody
an idea why
yes
yes correct you didn't restrict the
model because the the um the default in
this case here is extra
um I don't know it's not it's just like
to allow extra attributes and if an
attribute you send to your request model
is not just known it's just ignored and
this was happened here so the front of
the designer said okay well funnel
developer said hey cool I don't get a
complaint from the back end team nobody
noticed because
there was no exception nothing until
people realized oh okay
um somewhere in the business code also
no value was given they use the default
um and of course it didn't really work
as expected and nobody was able to
notice it so I think it's very important
so I my suggestion is always to uh not
to use uh extra allow to reuse extra
forbid to be I'm more like hey let's
make contracts that Define the models
they find it more in a strict fashion
because sometimes or very often teams
were distributed and with extra forbid
you're in the safe Zone it's a design
decision so if you like python code with
a lot of star double star quarks and
pass it around through many other
methods or classes
this then please do extra allow but if
you're more like like to design which is
more well defined extra for a bit I
think it's better for teams and
especially if you build critical
business
um applications
this was the first part about identity
field we'll come back to pedantic later
the next giant I really want to mention
and promote is Starlet actually so what
is Starlet Starlet this is just copied
from the Starlet
um website so style it is a lightweight
framework
um and you already see like oh HTTP
background task startup and shutdown
events
um and responses
um session cookie support you see
there's many features fast API exposes
also directly via fast API but you see
it's all basically it comes from Starlet
under the hood so I think it's very
important to not give all like a shout
out because I think style that they did
an amazing job
um but I think it's also like a very
good practice to look into the Starlet
documentation and to know better what
what is happening here how Starlet
handles things
so this is like a simple stalet example
so you build a middleware we add
middleware for example for context
um to to follow up on requests for
logging filtering stuff allowing things
it's just like a generic example and
then you already see like there's a ad
app on event startup you see okay it's a
startup when we basically can imagine
from just what I read on the slide
before hey this is just like a wrapper
who takes you to stalet from Fast API
and
and one use case we really had to go
deeper here um I want to summarize it
real short so um
we built an interface to a data Hub
um the data client is supposed to be a
convenient self-explanatory interface so
check fast API with all the
documentation every single text is a
very good choice but we also want to
um well we build a data client around it
so data client means that's this example
with client dot portfolio Benchmark just
like a simple function a business user
can easily remember and use this code
completion to say Okay I want to compare
two portfolios this is a finance boost
use case and I have one portfolio I want
to compare and I have a benchmark and a
benchmark if none is just like default
Benchmark which belongs to the portfolio
um that's a very simple interaction
there so
um fast API the data Hub uses fast API
we have a
easy simple endpoint portfolio Benchmark
and a request model IDE Benchmark and so
how can we generate the client
automatically what's the first question
and okay to sum this up in the use case
there's some Auto generators but they
did not meet any of our expectations in
coding standards redundancy also are in
terms of
uh yeah like many python object
connections which is lost because you
generate code again from the yaml and
you don't have a direct connection to
the python code which we were actually
looking for so
um the solution was actually to render
the client ourselves with Ginger 2 which
worked really well
um and but the other issue was that we
had some path parameters so if you put
something in the URL as query parameters
or to send data and
um
the model parameters which you can post
in adjacent so we wanted there were some
ambiguities we wanted to solve that was
a harder task and we were asking a
question can we fix it somehow in the
middleware and this took us to the
journey to enabling user with
simplifying interfaces with middleware
um so my suggestion is don't try this at
home
um so it was a spike story
to inspect how can the middleware help
to
mangle requests within the
um the middleware
um to moderate data to make the
interface easier for business users
especially and we found out it's very
complex and and and hard to to find
um it's solvable but it's not as easy as
you think because there's many
things that are not clear how actually
the inner mechanics work because a thing
here is we miss a lot of documentation
around here and this brings me to the
next topic so um there's great tutorials
with fast API and the ecosystem around
it but where are the doc strings
and so I counted the dog strings for
fast API I think that's one of the most
more recent version so fast API has 6
000 lines I even counted the empty
lights it has 259 classes
and 429 functions or methods and I only
was able to identify 11 dock strings so
is that a good number for Doc strings in
oh no I hear disagreement from the from
the audience
the design of Jose is with many layers
of instruction so even if you work in a
debugger so we would we really love to
work to use the debugger to see what's
really happening where is what is
happening where just find out with a
debugger to to to to correct the use
case but
sometimes it's or very often it was
really hard because there's no dog
string to give you a hint you're here
you hear this is happening here it's
basically just like a functions with
names and this is really hard to find
but also to I checked for Starlet
actually
um it's that's the wrong numbers let's
get that
um
I can tell you in the break I put on my
computer so uh yeah so it's I think it's
a call for more dog strings I don't know
why are there are so few dark strings
because around it there's many tutorials
great documentation but if you really
want to see something in context that's
really hard
um another very good learning was don't
repeat yourself with pedantic because of
course you start to build models like
the assets you there's more models
coming in there's more definition the
whole the whole thing grows um so this
is just like a little reminder for
everyone who's not familiar with
pedantic yet this is it's a very simple
model but as you see for example in the
next slide you could also abstract it
further like to say okay we just have
one model for the asset ID because we
want to make sure every model who
contains the para the asset ID
um should use the same and we just want
to re reuse it because we don't want to
rewrite repetitive examples because
writing your examples is not as easy as
you think and it's just like quite
boring as well so you can abstract this
into into multiple layers
like here and to for consistency for
reusability
um I'm I'm a strong believer in don't
repeat yourself try Computing so make
sure everything in your code you only
there's only one one line to fix things
or to update and this brings us to
pedantic inheritance which is also a
little bit I would we found it like
counter-intuitive like
um so we have decomposed everything here
into smaller pieces so we see we added a
period which is from to date asset name
and we all can basically compose it
together in the compose class here asset
asset ID and period and so we now have a
model with four attributes
this is really nice it's clean it really
helps we decided to build an internal
package around it and to make it
available to multiple other
in-house libraries but of course identic
inheritance has also like a little
danger zone for example here I updated
the validator we saw earlier with a star
so star says here well it does a star
has please validate each and every
attribute
but it's not the instruction please on
validate each and every attribute only
of the class where I reside basically
this is also inherited and if you have
this validator
in inheritance it will try to validate
everything and fun fact not everything
is an integer and this is basically also
misleading it's not another thing is
pedantic gives great exceptions readable
exceptions but sometimes it's really
hard if something art happens to find
out what is actually happening and
where's the oddness and sometimes it
points a bit on the wrong wrong side
so um to sum up the use case defining
models for an entire organization was
introduced and to introduce and enable
with standardization I'm a big fan of
standardization standardizing things and
discussing things up front and building
a nice architecture bringing everybody
on board especially departments uh from
the um from from the business know-how
side
um
it's really important to have clear and
concise design rules including naming
conventions and of course you can
centralize but also lessons weren't was
you can do too much centralization so
it's really good to have stuff like
asset something which is basically used
and repeated everywhere and in many
other libraries it's very good to
centralize them but you shouldn't be too
dogmatic about it because
um it's okay if another service defines
its own models reusing stuff from the
core Library thank you and
um and and yeah it's easier to Define
cross-organization attributes which are
like a very important core and others
you can Define yourself and you need
also somebody who takes these calls and
decisions in the team it's uh it should
be just not between the development
teams because this can be heated
um you need somebody to coordinate but
also to
promote hey we have this please use this
I mean what's this usually decentralized
organizations and many companies now
um I also want to notice five things I
love for the first API not only like
complaining and pointing I think the
accessibility in general due to the
design pattern of another layer of
extraction is great it's it's you can
really see what's happening until you
get lost
um missing dog strings a dynamic
creation of routers is great custom
validation for array handling is awesome
middleware is easy to add and the fifth
thing is actually five more things I
mean it has many great features so
um yeah and I think I have like one
minute left and I can take you to the
bonus
you can also render open eye API
instincts if you use Sphinx
documentation you don't necessarily need
to have a server running up to the open
API page here you can just like include
it into your documentation so all you
need is the things contribute open API
extension
you can add it to the things extensions
just like any other things extension
um the important things here are you
need to export your open eye definition
to a yaml file for example that's built
in
in fast APA already and guess what's the
latest hand so that is handling it
and you have to edit of course to your
index and another thing and this is like
the output here
um
you can just like add this page to your
documentation and things publish it on
the website you don't need to have a
server running to interact things and
then I thought this was really useful
and helpful and nice and
one more pointer here is you also need
to add this Dev setup somewhere in your
app if that's missing it's not taking
the connection that's um that's
something you just have to know but
friendly people on stack Overflow
referenced here
have published published it all right
um
thank you very much
awesome thank you so much that's really
interesting talk and it's really been
great to hear your perspective as well
can I add something please do yes I want
to thank my colleagues and peers
mentioned here on the slides yeah
because this is all team efforts and
learnings and very useful discussions
um yeah and also thanks for Lambda labs
for
putting the model online on hugging face
for the images
okay great so I've just got some
questions that have just come in now and
so I've got quite a few to ask you we've
got my three minutes so we'll do what we
can and we might be able to run over
very slightly because it is lunch next
you're also one I'm around run fast and
far
um first question here
um did you consider using flask or API
flask instead of fast API at any time
during this project no no
easy questions
okay
um how should you handle mapping between
different application layers and the
question is how should you handle
mapping between different application
layers oh yeah we're actually like
between application our solution was to
say to build a library and publicize it
internally but that's not as easy as the
thing sure yeah it's a lot of it's
basically more coordination than uh
coding problem sure fair enough
um so another question here from
Anonymous who writes in
um to ask the question what do you think
of the robustness principle that states
we should be liberal in what we accept
but conservative in what we send
considering the forbid option
well as I pointed out earlier I think in
business applications I'm rather say
let's define how we talk and the
protocol like on which data structures
we accept and which data structures we
will respond but I'm I know that are as
many use cases where flexibility is is
is more is better for the project it
actually I think it depends on the
business use case and if it's just like
okay we can ignore it and all is fine
it's good I mean I like to work
efficient and this is for many use cases
probably a more efficient way but in the
space where we use work is we have to be
like super reliable yeah because
mistakes there in backends can be
expensive
yeah I think a question that we
generally ask as well is what's the cost
of fixing a bug and that generally
so a few more questions for you and a
few more coming in
um one here and this is actually one I
had as well so thank you to Anonymous
for asking that one great work
um is uh so you chose to use a pedantic
inheritance rather than composing models
um I've definitely so I use pedantic in
my day job and I've definitely got into
composing model hell where I end up
composing something which is made up of
models and models and models like why
why was it why did you choose to do it
the way that you did
I actually was work in progress so
starting starting bring a team on also
at the client
one model at a time and then we thought
okay there's a lot of repetition and so
we decided for inheritance there's also
multiple other ways you can even build
models just like from code or jaml
definitions but we decided against that
in this case because for us a call
complication in the IDE is very
important and we don't really want stuff
to be generated yeah we found the same
actually uh generating from a very
complicated open API spec wasn't again
actually we also found out you can
really generate code with ginger too
it's really good so I'm a big fan of
code generating at home now
yeah so okay got some more questions we
have some more ones about the talk but
there is one that's overwhelmingly been
upvoted which is where are you getting
those awesome pictures from memory
address or you know artist name please
uh oh actually the artist's name yeah
that's an interesting thing so actually
this is the stable diffusion model uh
from uh from Lambda Labs I found it on
hugging phase so it's a public model uh
so I said that thanks for sharing all of
the labs and uh actually as every image
generator it's a little bit more like
the challenge is now not to generate
images just to put in the right keywords
and actually so the artist keyword I put
in there was Max Ernst which is a German
serialist so and Mark's amps worked
really well because photorealistic
pictures don't they are locked like well
not really presentable yeah but Max
Ernst and serialism really worked great
uh but I'm yeah if you know other talks
for me I used to do style transfer for
like five six seven years now and this
is a new technologies but I had some
transfer from
arts and yeah so I had some names in my
head diggurira also works great
but when God also works great
but it's always starry night that's the
problem
because there's too much bias in the
models
that would make sense actually
um there's a few more questions coming
in
um so you know you are free to leave
lunch might be served at some point but
I'm going to keep asking them as long as
Alexander here is happy to answer yeah
there's lunch downstairs so I might see
a mad rush but um question here
um actually one that's just been upvoted
to the top where can I find your slides
oh I can publish them later on Discord
that was my plan um awesome Twitter
Discord or Twitter or alternatively I'm
sure you'll be around for the rest of
the conference people I'm around also if
you have a question or if you want to
connect yes you just there's a QR code
just connect on LinkedIn and I'm happy
to give you some guidance if needed
a few more questions uh what's a good
practice if you want to share the
pedantic models that you've created with
with your teams for example or python
back in with a reference and then you
want to integrate like how do you find
that process is for you no actually like
our way was to publicize internal models
but you also need an infrastructure for
that sure um yeah so but I think you
could accomplish the same just like by
sharing a library on a repo because it's
really easy so that's that's another
really handy thing to know if you are
those models and you want to share you
can also just pip minus E install them
so even if you make a new pull request
you don't need to reinstall it with Pip
it automatically
um updates whatever you updated because
like compiling and setting up everything
is sometimes time consuming yeah because
one of the challenges here is actually
there's a model update and some but
you're working on something else in the
application and somebody else does a
model update and then things keeping
things in this thing is with the
centralization that's that's an issue um
so it's that's a good work around it
especially when you start ramping things
up like once you have low extrapolation
standards and libraries and everything
builds up because it's this is just like
a process and it will take some time and
then until you have a certain amount of
stability but in the ramping up phase
it's really handy also to use install
sure we have a few more questions but I
think it's best to maybe let everyone go
for lunch now so
um you know and there are if there are
questions you can find Alex yeah
I'm at the clinic Swig pools
with the PlayStation thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you